you begin this hour with breaking news
from the netherlands where the court of
appeals has ordered oil giant shell to
pay compensation
to a group of nigerian farmers they
accused the company of destroying their
fishing villages as a result of
three oil spills it's the first time a
dutch company has been held liable for
actions by its foreign subsidiary
let's go straight to step fast and she's
standing by for us in amsterdam
and step the ruling then gone against
shell what did the court say
exactly it's a it's seen here as a clear
victory
according to the friends of the earth
and netherlands who actually filed this
case together with
four nigerian farmers against shell the
court said that the daughter company of
shell spdc in nigeria is liable for
the pollution that has happened over the
many years
by all pipes it's using in nigeria and
that it also
is seen that it has to pay for
compensation it's not said
how much but there will be compensation
paid to these farmers and another
interesting aspect of this verdict is
that the mother company shall also
is ordered to have its duty to clean
these pipes this is the first time that
the court has actually ordered
the motor company shell to clean its
pipes and that it has to implement a
detection system
in which it will make clear if there's
any leakages happening or not
this case has lasted 13 years and the
friends of earth
netherlands told me that there were
tears of joy after this
victory as they say there was one
downside
to this verdict according to them and
that's one village
uh hasn't uh been seen as
as a failing uh i mean this one village
still needs to have more information
provided to the court before a verdict
will be done in this case
but all the other villages that have
suffered very badly from this pollution
will now see some kind of compensation
okay step
thanks for bringing the latest places
there from amsterdam let's go to ahmed
idris he's
following the proceedings from abuja and
after
13 long years this case has lasted for
how's this news
going to be received by farmers in
nigeria
it will be greeted with relief and joy
and
uh by the way laura this is not the only
case
in court either in the netherlands or in
the uk why hundreds of people
have queued up to sue shell for
contaminating the niger delta
uh i spoke to an activist a short while
ago he said this is just the beginning
and a lot of analysts also believe
that it will open the floodgates into so
many litigations against
all producing companies oil production
companies
that have been operating in nigeria some
of these cases
uh have been there for a very long time
and
they were unsuccessful several
communities were unsuccessful to try
call a shell in nigerian courts for
example in this particular case
rule today in the netherlands two of the
people who filed that case
uh have died have already died but again
activists are saying that this could
lead to more
litigations against shell and other
international oil companies
here in nigeria meanwhile the cleanup
process
in the niger delta is uh proceed
progressing but
slowly uh in in that area communities
are worried that
this could take a long time to
accomplish
workers agitate a riverbed to flush out
trapped oil in bordeaux creek
as it all comes to the surface a boom
traps the sludge
for evacuation it's a job the contract
contractors hired by all giant shell
must quickly accomplish before the tide
returns
the cleanup is due to litigation against
the company following a massive oil
spill in ogoni
in 2009 the scope of this work is to
remediate
uh the polluted areas in border creek
and after that the next phase will be
the restoration
revegetation of the mangroves and the
monitoring
so far is a 1000 hectares
while shelling's contractors say they've
done a lot of some sites
the nigerian government-led
decontamination effort jointly funded by
the shell company
is off to a slow start heavy machinery
is now deployed further inland
to excavate and treat contaminated soil
we are not on target from what we had
planned but we're trying to see what we
can do to catch up
there's still a lot of work to do to
catch up a meteor target
an assessment by the united nations
environment program first published in
2011
shows that pollution from more than half
a century of oil production
was worse than originally thought the
report recommended a one billion dollar
fund to clean up agony alone
an area covering 1 000 square kilometers
the work which began success later could
take at least 25 years to complete
much of ogoni is a wasteland this
mangrove is dead
as fish and crustaceans no longer spawn
here
farmlands fish ponds and even
underground water supplies
have been polluted by hydrocarbons
leaking from old pipelines
we could expect some activists in the
region are less impressed with the work
so far
other communities in the niger delta
felt that
if it works for the oguni people then
there is hope
for other communities in the niger delta
because the oguni
case is just one case
out of several several communities in
the niger delta
and how many years down the line we are
not getting it right
in a goodness and that's not the only
concern
significant amount of oil theft
continues in the region
further complicating the process of
reversing the environmental damage
experts believe 15 to 20 000 square
kilometers more
of nigeria's oil producing region
require the attention
organi is currently receiving they fear
that unless the entire region is
decontaminated
orgonic's cleanup may in the end be a
waste of time and resources
as recontamination could occur
laura the pipelines that have been laid
since the 1950s in niger delta to
extract oil and ship it outside of
nigeria
are still there a lot of
environmentalists are concerned that
these pipes
have gotten bad and continue to leak oil
into the environment and apart from that
this
is only a fraction of the niger delta
that we're talking about
20 times that size the size of ogoni
is still not properly or environmentally
accessed for
the damage done to the environment by
all uh
exploration in the niger delta so it
could be ages before
these communities will find peace the
environment will be remediated
and the natural environment the fish
fishes animals and plants can come back
to life so it's
we're looking at generations to come
before this is done orgoni itself
could take 25 to 30 years to clean up